uh what have you guys been watching
recently [ __ ] all man
you know watching anything retiring
right now i mean uh aki watched
uh uzaki-chan the other day ah how was
that she watched the first episode and
then she was like
you're gonna want to watch this so i
watched the first episode actually this
morning right like before we came to the
office
and uh i can't [ __ ] stand it
i'm sorry yes same here i'm sorry i'm
here
aki [ __ ] hates it i [ __ ] hate it
it is so [ __ ] boring
i saw her like a clip of it i haven't
watched it by the way but i saw a clip
where she got stuck in a bush
yeah yeah and to me it just looked like
the the pornhub thing where they get
stuck in the water
you know when they get stuck in the
washing machine yeah i thought it was a
hentai because i was like oh is this an
evolution you know i think i would enjoy
it if it was a hand time yeah
because that is like hentai material i
mean it's literally like the stuck in
the wall
tag that you have without the actual
[ __ ] i thought because the the
laundry thing had been blowing up
recently yeah
yeah but i mean it's propped up a lot of
porn recently so i thought oh it's a
hentai thing yeah yeah yeah
which is i guess that's just like what
everyone assumes about anime anywhere
yeah what is it about like
it's it's literally just a slice of life
where you follow this like
loud lolly who has big titties i'm like
i i i get the appeal of it because it's
blowing up
because she's a loud lolly with big
titties that's why
that's literally it it looks [ __ ] that
is her her body is her
personality yeah oh my god like it's
she's become the new
meme girl of the of the month i guess
because she
the manga has been pretty popular or at
least popular within certain circles
because i see her face
everywhere yeah it's everywhere i don't
understand why that well i
i reckon what it is it's that uzaki-chan
for like this new year or i guess maybe
this i don't know i don't want to say
this generation
but uh it's essentially the same as um
yeah right like
um is the exact same type of show where
if you can stand umachan and you can
relate and like umaru-chan
then you probably love them right yeah i
couldn't stand in my channel i'm like
this little turd
is [ __ ] taking advantage of her
brother so [ __ ] hard i would have
slapped the [ __ ] out i wanted to
stomp legit like i was just and so
i feel that uzaki-chan is like kind of a
similar show where like if you don't
like uzekijn as a character then you
won't be able to stay on the show
because
she is the entire show yeah it's like
watamote as well right like
if you if you don't like kuroky which i
didn't i couldn't [ __ ] stand it
because
because like the whole show is just
basically her annoying the [ __ ] out of
the main character
and the main character's like well i
hate you but you know that's her
personality
it's that she's [ __ ] annoying which
is really funny because people are like
oh it's just not that annoying
when a lot of people don't realize the
name uzaki is a play on words in
japanese for usaid which means annoying
that's why she's called uzaki it's
because she's [ __ ] annoying
and like yeah because i know so many
people like
friends of owls right like dakota's a
[ __ ] massive fan of that show and i'm
just like
why yeah dakota why why why why why
dakota what does it say about you as a
person
is it because she has a [ __ ] skin
fang and has two big tits like is is
that it like why
what the fang what's white i'll tell you
why it's because the dojinshi's are good
but like
this is like one of those shows where
it's it's it's it's its own specific
genre now i swear to god well i swear
there are just some shows or some manga
that i swear people make just because
they like
oh this is gonna be good the ginger
material yeah that's what that's that's
gonna be the top
genre of these shows the genre is doji
material yeah that's what it is because
they always have like the meme girl like
it's it's always focused on this one
meme girl that a lot of people may find
annoying
but for some reason she just works
written really good
like in any situations in dojinshi's
they they just like they're just golden
oh yeah because as as much as i don't
dig the uzaki-chan anime man the
uzaki-chan dojins are [ __ ] lit
my god the guys are degenerative every
single one that i have seen so if i'm
just like damn son i wish i could read
porn i just can't a monkey brain man
it's like i mean you don't have to i
mean you you call it you can't you don't
read anyway let alone
read porn yeah so how am i gonna read
that's like that's
even worse than the gaming thing with
reading like i don't wanna breed my porn
i want shitty acting and i wanna
skip to five minutes in and then decide
what i'm gonna do it's because uh's
personality is so
fit for dojin she's because she's like
that like always teasing kind of
character right and i'm just like well
if you put that in the sexual aspect
man that makes for some spicy dojins
yeah they are they're really [ __ ]
good
and it her big tits don't help honestly
her body proportions do not help
right i would i don't think i would
enjoy the uzaki chandojians if her body
was just like
normal yeah yeah exactly but because
it's so disproportioned and built for
dogens i'm just like
yeah there's clearly plenty it's it's
just the show that's made for hentai
like even more so than some fan service
see edgy shows there are just like there
are like some etching shows
and then there are edgy shows that are
made i feel just for like the fan
material under the existence
it's like it's like being like oh yes
this new arrowgate came out but i'm
gonna get the all-ages version instead
yeah why why would you do that to
yourself why what's the point in that
so out of ten the first episode like a
three yeah
at least that sounds generous it looks
good that's all i'm gonna like
okay i'll admit uzekijn's character
design [ __ ] amazing i love it it's
great i i
reckon that's why a lot of people got
drawn into it because her character's
design is great
i love her character design and she has
such a good memeable face
you know you know that one girl every
season that just has the best facial
expression oh yeah like this season is
definitely
it's definitely uzaki shawn like her
smug face the smug energy
the smug face yeah that's what she's got
like the perfect smug face
but other than that anime fans are just
like it's a great show it's got a smart
face i'm sold i'll pick it
it's it's this is art congratulations
smug face
anime fans are the real monkey brains i
just
genuinely want to know like for people
who are watching this right now and
saying that they love uzaki-chan
what is it about the show that you like
because i tried
right i always do my best even if it's a
show i don't like i'm like okay
why is it that people are getting into
the show like what aspects is it yeah i
looked at uzaki china i'm just like
the only thing i can think of is her
tits
that's the only redeeming factor about
this show and i feel bad because i feel
like that's
the easy to go to like oh this this show
has no substance or anything but
i i legitimately like i just i'm just
curious i want to know why
yeah it's not like i'm like trying to
like diss on people who like the show
like by all means right
but i just want to know like what is it
is it if it isn't the tits
because if that's the case this is like
a call for help because if that's the
case right then
you could literally just be like okay i
[ __ ] hate this anime
but if i add tits seven out of ten this
feels like an intervention it's like
just make you have a problem just
tell us just admit that you like the
tits and that's the only reason why i
enjoy this show